Gettys grape
what's the one-trick pony oh what's up
I'm Blake and I'm iffy and we're gonna
be picking dates off of meals yes I'm
ready
it's our time yes our time yeah we get
to taste you know put the tastes to the
test like a taste test that is what
we're doing yeah
that is the mmm hey guys I'm Bethany I'm
count and I'm Alex and today we are
cooking meals for single men trying to
get a date sketch one that's fun catch
mom you know they say the way to a man's
heart is through his stomach
Joe last time we did all right me and
you we were the winners cue
unfortunately well fortunately for us he
cheated he cheated no he got like a
horrible meal yeah let's get this first
meal let's start tasting all right so I
just went to the grocery store I
originally wasn't quite sure what I
wanted to make for the guys but I have
been eating more vegan myself if there's
one thing I do know that's important
about dating it's that you need to stay
true to who you are you can't change
yourself or anyone else and that means
I'm gonna make something vegan all right
so here's the plan I'm going to be
making a vegan version of a classic
spaghetti and meatballs I decided to
just keep it pretty simple just because
guys are pretty simple I forgot one keen
reading and that is eggs so eggs are
what holds and buying a meatball
together I don't know I can please based
on that but eggs are also non vegan so
I'm gonna pivot and I'm just gonna make
a bone a sauce it'll be just as
delicious it's just not in [ __ ] we're
gonna watch Alex's me waiter know that
looks good this looks fantastic
oh yeah I mean I don't see that yeah
I'll say off rip they already
yeah what's great is about the amount of
parmesan I usually use on my pasta like
it looks like a you know snowy
mountaintop that's me I did sprinkle a
ton of garlic salt on top of that's what
I do they don't know it's vegan that's
the thing it's vegan oh my god that
sorcery okay that was genius
I mean this is good this is fantastic
the Bible in order to a girl's house she
made me this I would be super happy I'd
be like it's all ours simple you know
pasta blowing yes you know what is it
what is that going yes that's the word
for the video today remember it takes
you on a date I mean overall we're gonna
like rate this this is an 8 out of 10
meal presentation is off the chart
flavor so solid now if you'll excuse me
I'm gonna take this giant bite yeah
yeah the same thing to me I'd say you
know I know coming out the gate strong
is the one to beat so let's see what's
next
they didn't even know that was my goal I
don't even care if I win or not they
didn't know it was vegan I'm nervous now
like a DB tonight right very visually
one point but
target culture a person you know
totally vegetarian okay
all right I think I got it you know easy
simple chicken
broccoli potato having loves meat potato
a 2-man fit the data for the one all
right this is Kiana's yeah number two
mutant number two what it do oh thank
you Quentin
oh okay looks very gourmet broccoli
potatoes and chicken this I mean I'm
just gonna say the presentation of
theirs makes us look like jokes I mean
mine was slapping but mine looks great
like I exactly something out of a
restaurant looks so good
I also realized I've never had anyone
like review my food before I'm letting
the food talk to me you know cause you
know a lot of people you know they they
eat and they they make the decision when
you sell but if you listen the food
talks to you eats more okay I'm not
you're like I just getting harder to eat
okay I'm actually gonna give this one an
8.5 spaghetti is great what's the
one-trick pony oh this you have two
sides and the main part that's what
that's nice I like that this is gives
you a little bit everything I said that
men were just so simple I'm just gonna
do spaghetti I'm put some respect on
spaghetti 's name I'm never gonna call
it a one-trick pony and it does it gets
the job done
I'm attired it's gonna be another nine
possibly nine point five for this this
is this is another banger for me this
was amazing but I think I'm gonna eat
that third meal and run my mouth that
big number three yeah really
break him down
[Music]
perfection is hey guys
so I'm doing a little bit of last-minute
shopping right now and I decided to cook
some salmon because I love salmon so
much it's very light very filling as
well and it's probably the easiest thing
that I could I was like racing here two
routes as I have to head straight to the
studio after this okay so I'm gonna
blame it all on cue I did not know I
supposed to come with my groceries
already like my entire meals just be
already made so I just brought groceries
but instead I'm just gonna probably
order something from room braids and
hopefully they like it
okay saw me I'm nervous about the new
plate number three okay she's got a
salad on the side
I'm allergic to avocados really man oh
my dad is too chicken is a Greek el
Diablo that's very spicy like that let's
have a little coke - yeah he's dying to
know what mm-hmm
I mean I'm like a little more protein
but you know besides that this one is
the only one that came with a salad
though is good at they're being held
conscious to have a salad on the side
it's good to eat this way I'm like I
don't all normally eat this way but it's
good - yeah no this is fantastic I'm
gonna put this one below the other two
though yeah I think tasting this I give
this is the last thing I needed to taste
to really come to my like decision I
think I pretty much decided they were
all fantastic
I just decided which one would be the
best one for me which one I would like
to have the most often and we're just
you know dating a girl or something like
that so um yeah step on your toes or
anything but I'm gonna have taken over
too I think okay well you're not
stepping on my toes because there we go
the decision I came to was number one
I'd say number one because I think the
thought that goes into making pasta to
impress someone like that's the type of
energy I'm looking for in a partner
where it's like yeah like it just makes
me think of Olive Garden when you're
here you're family I mean I pick number
two because I feel like she went a
hundred percent and that's kind of my
style and she's gonna go hundred percent
on the meal relationship probably
hundred percent on life she wanted not
fair I want a rematch
okay it's so interesting seeing yourself
like being represented by something so
physical yeah it was funny because when
I was thinking of what to do I was a
little hesitant to make anything vegan
because I was like man had me
but I was like you know what a part of
dating is staying true to who you are
you know I'm gonna do it and it paid off
because I got a date if you're broken
that they did not enjoy here with you
while we cooked the bay and then we
conquered conquered yeah sweet freedom
I'm gonna go get on tinder so let's meet
the ladies
behind the meals we did it we did it how
does it feel to be on the other side
it's definitely stressful yeah but
anyways yeah this was fun y'all are both
amazing yeah chef
well I picked number two and I picked
number one so what if I told you that
the plate was vegan then a pasta dish
serving but that was the way the reason
I thought that was my thinking through
it was that it came when you know
vegetables and everything so very good
like she went all out she always goes
all out I'm happy with what happened I
mean are you
what is like very complimentary I think
this could be like a new movement and
dating yeah yeah I'd like it to the
roles to be reversed though that's the
true test
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]